tulsi gabbard former congresswoman and
presidential candidate joins me now
congresswoman that seemed to be a
critical
piece of paper we signed
with the ukrainians in november just a
few months ago basically saying yeah
you're nato you're on the way you're
getting there you're close
did anybody in washington think that
might have been a little provocative and
i'm not blaming the americans for
everything that russia does
i'm just saying it takes a little touch
to handle a buffer state like ukraine
don't you think so
yeah jesse you know as you said there is
so much
devastation and incredible suffering uh
that's going on in ukraine right now and
the world needs to condemn putin for
his actions
the thing here is
that our leaders really have this fu
attitude
and they just don't care
we see this fu attitude in our domestic
policy here at home
where they're saying you know what fu to
parents who are concerned about what
their kids are being taught in their
schools uh you know fu to americans who
want to make their own decisions as it
relates to their health and covid
and then you see this same attitude and
mindset also extending to their
decisions on our foreign policy
basically going in and saying you know
what this is what we're going to do
any other country in the world and
there's nothing that anybody can do
about it there's nothing anyone can do
to stop us and and all of this just
points to the fact that that they just
don't care because jesse if they did
then before making these decisions
before taking these actions they would
stop and think for more than just a
moment about what the ramifications and
consequences of those decisions will be
who will they impact the most how will
they impact the american people the
people of these other countries uh what
what will the cost be is it worth it
what is our objective and what are we
trying to accomplish does it serve the
best interest of our country these are
the things that they would be
considering before they make these
decisions uh and and it's just clear to
me that they're not and and i just i
look back to
1996 something that exemplifies this fu
attitude and their lack of care for
people was when madeleine albright was
asked about uh her reaction to the
sanctions u.s sanctions policy against
iraq that had killed 500 000 kids and as
you know her response was chilling when
she said
it was worth it
well the byte administration is going to
have to ask themselves this question
is this worth it
i looked at the market today when i came
into work it's down what 700 800 points
people are losing their jobs people will
have to choose whether they're going to
buy groceries or gasoline oh and by the
way americans
are possibly going to enforce a no-fly
zone and
thousands of innocent civilians are
dying
in ukraine and it seems like we just
hurdled ourselves into the situation
right after a pandemic tulsi
right when we're trying to recover from
a pandemic we're trying to keep our eye
on china we're trying to make sure the
american people are healthy and can work
and can live
and now we're in a war in europe almost
and we can't afford anything and we're
facing a recession
do you think anybody thought this
through
it certainly doesn't seem like it
or a more cynical view was that they did
think it through and what is playing out
is exactly what they had aimed for the
greatest tragedy in all of this jessie
is that this devastation all of this
suffering that's going on
this could have been prevented
had we had leaders who put the interests
of people first
i agree
i agree and again
not our fault
but
we're here
and we have to take responsibility for
what we did
and there's no doubt about that
thank you very much tulsa gabriel
thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else